Moscow controlled regions in eastern and
southern Ukraine are voting on whether
to become part of Russia the referendums
are taking place in luhansk Donetsk
zaparisha and Carson that's about 15 of
Ukraine's territory cave and its Western
allies say the votes are sham and an
unlawful land grab it comes as Ukrainian
forces continue to recapture swaths of
territory in a major counter-offensive
or for more on today's referendum let's
speak to khada Abdul Hamid she's joining
us live from pokrosk in Ukraine um give
us some background to this what's going
on why is the referendum being held
well people are being asked whether they
want to join the Russian Federation or
not now this has been long time in the
coming the ground for all of this has
been set back in 2014 when the uh
pro-russian separatists in dunyats and
Logan's regions first started making
their demands at the time they had
proclaimed these two republics they said
they were independent from Ukraine but
no one had recognized them for about
eight years not until two days before
this war started so on February 22nd
when President Vladimir Putin made an
official recognition of those two places
but the demand had always been to join
the Russian Federation and actually
Russia has been Distributing Russian
passports not only in Donetsk and
lugan's in the areas under separatist
control but also recently in for example
zaporija Russia holds up about half of
that region in the Carson region in the
south of the country so that this has
been well prepared in for a long time
the one issue you have there is that not
all of the original residents of those
regions are still there to actually vote
uh the vast majority of people living in
Indonesia and dugans had already left
eight years ago more left when the war
started either towards Ukraine or
towards
Russia so you have the issue about who
exactly is voting and how can that be
legitimate considering that the original
residents are not in those areas at this
point I know you've been talking to a
few of the people who are remaining in
in those areas how are people feeling
about this vote
now I talked to people who actually left
those areas
many of them reached zeppo region the
Ukrainian control side that would be
their first stop to then move uh further
Westward or towards Western Ukraine or
even Poland and now they were saying yes
there is a part of the population in
those areas that do support uh Russia
they would say mostly the elderly and
that is something that I've actually
witnessed myself for example in the in
the in the land in places that the
ukrainians have recently retaken cities
like balaclia and izum you had people
there who were supporting Russia who'd
had no problems living during the
Russian occupation they said they had
food they had water they had electricity
so that things were not too bad as long
as you didn't get involved with the
Russians there is that mentality still
but this seems to be a bit of a
generation will divide there I've heard
very few young people actually showing
support to the Russian occupation